[Music]
foreign
hey guys Hallie here and you know what
else is here Valentine's Day as et's
resident lifestyle expert I've got your
back when it comes to dishing out the
perfect sweet treat that'll give your
leading love real life heart eyes ready
for it oat milk chocolate brownies
topped with white chocolate frosting and
dried rose petals because let's be real
nothing says l-o-v-e Love Like Roses in
fact these brownies are so good even
Cupid will be saying
to get started you'll need one cup flour
a fourth a cup cocoa powder 1 cup sugar
a third cup vegetable oil 1 teaspoon
vanilla extract a half a cup melted
chocolate one cup Planet oat dark
chocolate oat milk 3 4 cup chocolate
chips and edible rose petals kick things
off by preheating your oven to 350
degrees and lining your baking dish with
parchment paper then and take a large
bowl and throw your flour cocoa powder
and sugar together and whisk it up until
combined next add your oil vanilla
chocolate and chocolate oat milk mixing
until it's nice and smooth I'm using
Planet oat oat milk because it's rich
and creamy and delicious and really
elevates the overall flavor of this
dessert
and since there are no eggs feel free to
lick that spoon and really Savor the
smooth creamy taste to plant it out
before adding in your chocolate chips
foreign
batter into the baking dish and pop it
in the oven for about 30 to 40 minutes
and while those are baking let's get
started on the frosting you'll need
three ounces of white chocolate one
tablespoon butter 1 cup confectioner
sugar and four to six tablespoons
planted oat oat milk melt your chocolate
and butter in the microwave for 15
second intervals stirring well each time
until it's nice and gooey add your
confectioner sugar and three tablespoons
of oat milk stirring to combine adding
in one additional tablespoon of oat milk
at a time until you get that desired
consistency
once the brownies are done spread the
frosting on top and sprinkle dried rose
petals on top for a fancy festive touch
forget your traditional Valentine these
babies are a million times sweeter than
a love letter serve with a cold glass of
Planet oat milk or box them up gift them
to a friend and spread the love
[Music]